hello guys I'm Ryan right
I'm Caroline Mills Caroline Mills I know
her cut from acting class or I don't
even like to call it acting really it's
more about the art of being and feeling
and then it is about acting acting is
faking acting a sudden it's such a turn
it's such a it's life thank you
why do we use it I'm just expressing
oneself in multiple forms in a day it's
a beautiful thing honestly that was
great back and forth
thank you should put us up for improv
together in class and there's time go
let's let's volunteer ourselves and
we'll plan the whole improv Caroline and
I her first time on the channel and I
thought you know what this would be a
great warm-up video Mortal Kombat X I'll
every new fatality x-ray and brutality
alien try Borg leather face boat ride
yeah I asked her how she feels about
gore before filming she said that she
can handle it but she steers away from
it yeah I get blood in me aren't like
best friends but you believe once a
month don't you I do
you're correct I'm a woman that's called
menstruating science people it's a great
thing he's best time for the month to
have sex right there feels better
anyways I really hope it doesn't like
make me nauseous to smell this blood um
I once got nauseous and had to leave and
I threw up a tiny bit you should be
nervous I don't really
[Applause]
you must never look away by the way Oh
No
[Music]
alien franchise
my you are going to town my friend
Leatherface win it tribal wins
[Music]
[Applause]
wins the mission I have sex
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
whistles Wow
[Applause]
I can do that I'm fair enough your
technique is he lucky it's not bad I'll
get a new office your technique is lucky
where are we excuse me
you're lucky
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
Leatherface
if you were still alive why'd you try to
get Leatherface myself game victory
[Applause]
[Music]
I know I know wow that was awesome in so
many different ways that was awesome
poison violence and Gorm's gonna keep a
plane in the back room while we talk
about
wow so what'd you think Caroline tell
the audience what you thought that was
not what I was expecting when you said
animated and gore yeah what are you
totally intimated you were like like
Disney animated like animated I was
talking about Zootopia at that moment oh
yeah which by the way is a great [ __ ]
movie yeah for all you mortal kombat
fans I'm telling you utopias the film
for you animals yeah getting along I
played Mortal Kombat XXL it sounds great
I've played Mortal Kombat X and that's a
total blast of the video again
honestly this stuff is cooler when
you're behind the controller and then
you're actually doing it to someone I
understand that yeah I can get that
however like my expansion of moral
common playing was like the stand-up one
and like an arcade where you like punch
the button yeah yeah I've done so to see
this like I was never expecting them to
dice them in half and put them on a
butcher hook and let their o and let
them throw intestines I know my Mortal
Kombat was like pun fun punch kick kick
kick honestly though when you're playing
like if you were playing against each
other and if you were able to do one of
these combinations to me one of these
like fatalities I think you get a total
high out of it
no no what if you were already high
prior and then you did it and you got
even more high actually I think the
problem with the video game is when
you're high it makes it that much more
intense be high makes everything more
than it does don't know why I keep doing
it because it's also [ __ ] amazing I
don't think I'm gonna do this one I'll
never have the technique of Leatherface
which is just disappointing because
honestly those those were very gruesome
but they were impressive
yeah impressive impressive English but I
like what they do a leather face and
alien the xenomorph is because I really
like those movies in general so the fact
that they put them in these video games
they were able to turn them into this
light computer animation that moves
faster and it's scary the way they're
making them move you know like it's it's
really scary and I'm like whoa [ __ ]
usually even horror they have to be kind
of slow but no that's terrifying doesn't
make it feel more realistic to you
because they move more quickly no no it
doesn't I I know you were hoping that
question would lead down a better
conversation but for your first video
you have failed in your question asking
towards Ryan welcome to the real world
Caroline you I've been welcomed I'm here
that's good yeah if you're new to the
channel listen listen you little [ __ ]
kids I swear to god I'm gonna do all
these Mortal Kombat fatalities to each
individual Latino kid outside I hope
they can hear me I'm kind of whispering
so they don't hear me I'm really tell
their parents they might tell me I was
telling I think I told you the other
night right about how like me kids came
knocking on my door are you Ryan right
that's that's awesome that you guys are
fans I don't want to lose the
subscribers of course thank you
but don't go knocking on my door we're
obviously busy to make these videos for
you unless you have Little Caesars Pizza
again greet me rape me and if you have
an 18 year old with you you're welcome
into my apartment if you guys are new to
the channel subscribe today become a
reject Caroline what exactly do you want
me to promote for you right now this
very moment
oh your social networks the fact that
you have a channel in the works what is
it that you want me to have people help
you become aware of something about
Caroline you can follow my Instagram
it's Caroline Gibson mills I do have a
channel in the works I know my own very
sincere delivery you thank you you can
follow me on Instagram
Caroline Mills I have a channel norc's
it's Eli Mills we're working on it
obviously I need a little help a little
help follow it though if you want to
follow up before I get anything up that
is super cool following an advance that
way when it's uploaded you're the first
to know
yeah I mean I do fun stuff I talked
about many things
not a porn star people she's a
respectable actress
honestly I'm swear